today is national beer day yeah we said
who has the credentials
who can we send on this kind of story
and
it was a unanimous decision jc fernandez
downtown
at craft house brewery how you doing jc
first off guys happy national beer day
cheers to you and i think you sent the
wrong guy down because literally before
we went on
i just i spilled the beer on the counter
party foul on me i spilled the mirror
right before we went live on tv but hey
it's showbiz this is wendy she's with
craft house brewery
and wendy thank you so much for having
us you're going to educate us
on beer you got three beers here what's
the difference between the three beers
that we're looking at
so the first beer here that is our
number one best seller that's silver
state that's our blonde ale so that's
going to focus on the hot on the malt
excuse me
so it's going to be nice round not
attacking with the hops
i see a lighter beer does this mean less
alcohol in this drink uh
in this one but that's not always a rule
of thumb okay and this one looks like a
darker beer is this a lager
it is that's our cuckoo munich uncle
lager now when i think lager i think of
drinking something like this like it's a
meal is this
is this a heavy beer it is not so the
lager yeast means it finishes lighter
okay so i didn't know that it's a
lighter beer and then the last one here
tell me about this beer right here
that is dry heat that's our hazy ipa or
new england ipa
and that focuses on the hops on the hops
okay now you you told me i poured my
beer incorrectly what's the proper way
to pull to pour a beer so you're going
to want to rinse your glass first
rinse it right here i know this yep
clean glass yeah okay
and then you're going to want to angle
it at 45 degrees angle it
this is the proper way to pour a beer
and you get less you get less head on
top right
well you get the right amount okay and
then sort of angle it out
to now go oh that is perfect well yours
is much better than mine mine looks like
an amateur right here
i have a little more practice you've got
experience all right we're back in the
four o'clock hour coming up in the four
o'clock hour i'm gonna tell you the
difference between
growlers and crawlers correct all right
cheers to you guys happy national beer
day we'll send it back to you in the
studio
hey so you spilled a little beer no big
deal jason no big deal
no big deal you can't make an omelet
without cracking some eggs